he is an astrophysicist with the
american museum of natural history
host of the webby award winning podcast
star talk and author of the new book boy
is he busy cosmic queries please welcome
our friend neil degrasse tyson is over
here
hello mr personality
how are you doing man good always good
to see you just trying to keep the
universe
up i know and i have so many great
questions you've got to do it
you are the sheriff that you said for
the universe i always call you
uh but uh the book great book because
it's sort of like a companion piece to
your podcast which is awesome and it's
about the big questions and
i'm going to get to the biggest one
first jewish space lasers how do the
jews get them up there
jews are all powerful apparently yes
okay but the questions you're really
asking are the the ones that
you know i always say the ones that make
your head hurt yeah
because they're you know you can go the
big bang we're going to get into that
but like
what happened what's before the big bang
that's a head hurter
why is there anything right what i mean
these are whole chapters in the book
i know that's why i'm bringing it up
you know why is there anything and if
there was nothing is nothing not
something
oh that's your that's your opening salvo
okay
take it away all right uh while i give
you an answer just contemplate
this if pinocchio said
my nose is about to grow right what
would it do
i get it just think about that while i i
know give you the answer to the liar
no there's a whole the book opens with
just how
did it all begin but it goes through
these other questions that we've
all carried with us if you didn't carry
it with you you stumbled on it
and then you took pause in your life to
reflect on it how did it all begin
what's it all made of
are we alone in the universe that's big
news of recent months
and how will it all end i'm going to get
to that but let's forget with how it all
began
first because um i want to ask you about
the big bang theory
okay not the show the actual theory if
you type big bang theory into google
first thing is this
is the tv show and i don't know if
that's good or bad that's bad
okay we know that's bad okay okay
so okay but you're the guy who can
answer this question for me
how settled is it because on a scale of
evolution okay when when dart darwin's
origin of species was published in 1859
it wasn't settled science in 1860 they
debated it for decades
as science should people said well let's
try to poke holes in it they didn't
now it's settled science i'd like to say
the same thing about
global warming being man-made i think it
is in the scientific community not so
much in the political community
but what about the big bang theory is
that something
we're totally now everybody who has your
brain
all those eight people
they're down with this yes because it's
settled
it satisfies all of the
observational data that needs accounting
for
are neatly contained within the
understanding that comes to us from the
big bang
the universe is bigger today than it was
yesterday the universe is hotter
yesterday than it was today so
you go back far enough 14 billion years
right all of the known universe was in
the same place at the same time
at a stupendously high temperature
then you could say how do you know you
weren't there well
if if matter and energy are at that
temperature it comes with consequences
so we say what would happen if matter
and energy were at that temperature for
this long you get about this much
hydrogen in the universe about that much
helium you get this
it was all condensed yes i mean this is
amazing because we're talking about
trillions yes of stars which are
big way more than trillions yeah okay
all in one
okay why do it that way why start the
universe that way like boom bang let's
all
mash it up and then boil it up why do it
that way that's why people invent
religion
to account for why
in science we will tell you how that
happened right but you want to know if
there's purpose
to it uh that's a philosophical
bordering on religious question
that some people feel the need to reach
for and possibly find
and many questions on the frontier of
our knowledge frontier of our ignorance
lands squarely in the lap of the
armchair philosopher
or the religious uh holy person on the
mount
so okay right that's neither of us
neither that's correct but i'm content
saying i can explain this
i know i i know i can account for how
that happens
okay and that's that's a profound place
to be because most of the history
of human civilization we had no
accounting of things
i mean it sounds crazy but you're a lot
smarter than the preacher so i'm going
to go with you okay
you